>> Laura: TIME FOR SEEN AND
UNSEEN WHERE WE REVEAL THE
STORIES BEHIND THE HEADLINES AND
FOR THAT WE TURN TO FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND AUTHOR OF THE
WISE MEN WHO FOUND CHRISTMAS
RAYMOND ARROYO.
ALL RIGHT, RAYMOND, TELL US
ABOUT THIS MOVIE CALLED BROS
WHICH WAS BILLED AS AS THE FIRST
MAJOR STUDIO GAME ROM-COM.
IT FLOPPED, I GUESS, AT THE BOX
OFFICE?
HOW COULD THAT BE?
>> OH, DID IT FLOP.
THIS MOVIE BROS COST UPWARDS OF
$60 MILLION TO MAKE AND PROMOTE.
IT CAME AT A DISTANT NUMBER FOUR
IN THE WEEKEND BOX OFFICE BARELY
MAKING $4.8 MILLION OVER THE
WEEKEND.
THE WRITER AND LEAD ACTOR BILLY
IKENER HAS BEEN SELLING IT HARD
FOR MONTHS.
>> IT OPENED SEPTEMBER 30TH, A
GREAT NEW COMEDY, HE MADE
BRIDESMAIDS KNOCKED UP IT'S
HILARIOUS.
>> WHERE CAN I SEE IT.
>> IN MOVIE THEATERS.
>> BROS.
>> YES.
>> THROUGH THE OBAMA YEARS IT
FELT LIKE WE WERE EVOLVING AND
WE WERE BUT UNDERNEATH THE
SURFACE THINGS WERE NOT
EVOLVING.
THERE WAS SO MUCH HOMOPHOBE I
CAN'T, CASE IN POINT BROS IS THE
FIRST GAY ROM-COM MADE BY SOCIAL
MEDIA.
>> IT COULD WELL BE THE LAST.
TODAY HE TRIED TO EXPLAIN AWAY
IT, HE TWEETED STRAIGHT PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY IN SERB PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY JUST DIDN'T SHOW UP FOR
BROS.
ANYONE WHO ISN'T A HOMOPHOBE
WEIRDO SHOULD GO SEE BROS
TONIGHT.
HOW DO HOMOPHOBES CONTROL GAY
MOVIE GOING.
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT HE HAD
THAT CONTROL OF GAY PEOPLE FROM
GOING TO MOVIES.
MAYBE PEOPLE JUST DIDN'T LIKE
THE MOVIE.
BROS HAD EXPLICIT SEX SCENES R
RATING SO SO REVIEWS AND BILLY
IKE NERIS NOT A LIKEABLE
PERSONALITY LAURA.
>> Laura: YEAH.
IT'S AN INTERESTING TACT TO TAKE
TO INSULT PROBABLY HALF THE
COUNTRY IN YOUR PUSH, AGGRESSIVE
PUSH TO SELL YOUR FILM.
THAT'S KIND OF AN INTERESTING
TAKE ON IT.
BUT THAT'S KIND OF WHAT HE DOES.
>> I JUST THINK PERHAPS THEY
TOOK THE WRONG LESSON FROM THE
SUCCESS OF TOP GUN.
ONLY THAT WAS A MOVIE GAY PEOPLE
SHOWED UP FOR.
MY FAVORITE WAS THE NEW YORK
TIMES ATTEMPT TO CLEAN UP THIS
BROS BOMB THE TIMES ADMITTED
IKENER CAN BE POLAR SIZES AS A
COMIC PERSONALITY AND OF COURSE
HOME FOAM I CAN'T CANNOT BE
RULED OUT BUT ROMANTIC COME DIS
HAVE STRUGGLED IN THE BOX OFFICE
IN RECENT YEARS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE BOX OFFICE
IS TALKING ABOUT.
SANDRA BULLOCK JUST RELEASED A
ROM-COM THE LOST CITY AND MADE
$30 MILLION ITS FIRST WEEKEND.
I THINK I'M STARTING TO
UNDERSTAND WHY BILLY IKENER IS
SO MEAN THOUGH.
EARLIER YOU ASKED ME WHAT DAY
WAS IT? OCTOBER 3RD, MEAN GIRLS.
CHECK THE REFERENCE.
>> Laura: AS LONG AS YOU'RE
INVOKING MEAN GIRLS, MAYOR
LATOYA CANTRELL HAS CONTROVERSY
AFTER SPLURGING ON LUXURY TO
FRANCE A COMMUNITY GROUP IS NOW
CHARGING HER WITH STAYING RENT
FREE, OF COURSE, IN A CITY-OWNED
APARTMENT.
IS SHE A SQUATTER?
WHAT?
>> WELL, SHE'S KIND OF AN
OFFICIAL SQUATTER.
AND IT'S NOT JUST ANY APARTMENT,
AN EXCLUSIVE APARTMENT RIGHT ON
JACKSON SQUARE.
THE COMMUNITY GROUP FOUND THAT
SHE PAID NO RENT FROM SEPTEMBER
OF 2021 THROUGH JULY OF THIS
YEAR.
SHE'S BEEN THERE FOR NINE
MONTHS, ACCORDING TO THIS GROUP.
THE PROBLEM IS, THERE'S A CITY
EMPLOYEE POLICY THAT STATES
CLEARLY THE USE OF CITY PROPERTY
IS FOR WORK-RELATED PURPOSES AND
NOT PERSONAL BENEFIT.
NOW, THE FOX AFFILIATE IN NEW
ORLEANS WVUE DID AN
INVESTIGATION AND FOUND MAYOR
OCCUPYING THIS CITY-OWNED
APARTMENT FOR NEARLY 26 DAYS.
LAURA.
THERE'S A SET ASIDE FOR LIKE,
YOU KNOW, VISITING DIGNITARIES
OR PARTIES.
IT'S NOT SUPPOSED TO BE AN
EXTRA, YOU KNOW, BACHELORETTE
PAD FOR THE MAYOR.
>> Laura: I MEAN, ALL
POLITICIANS CAN KIND OF MOVE
TOWARD THE FREE LOADER STATUS
AFTER BEING THERE FOR LONG
ENOUGH.
EVERYONE BECOMES A FREE LOADER
EVENTUALLY.
THIS IS THE ULTIMATE FREE
LOADER, LATOYA CANTRELL.
THIS WOMAN IS A MENACE.
>> WHEN YOU'RE THE MURDER
CAPITOL OF THE COUNTRY, YOU JUST
BLEW $30,000 ON A TRIP TO FRANCE
AND YOU OWE NOW $3,000 A MONTH
RENT AND THERE'S A RECALL
UNDERWAY, IT'S BEST NOT TO SQUAT
IN THE CITY'S PROPERTY.
BY THE WAY, THEY'VE ALREADY
COLLECTED 10,000 SIGNATURES, 20%
OF THE SIGNATURES THEY NEED FOR
THAT RECALL EFFORT.
SO THINGS ARE NOT LOOKING GOOD
FOR THE MAYOR.
>> Laura: NO.
>> FINALLY LAURA TESLA JUST
UNVEILED A NEW HUMAN OID ROBOT.
WHY AM I GETTING VIBES ON THIS
THING I DON'T LIKE THE LOOK OF
THIS AT ALL.
WHAT MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW IS
THESE ROBOTS MAY ALREADY BE IN
USE AS PUBLIC ANNOUNCERS AND
TALK SHOW GUESTS.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO SAY I TOLD
YOU SO.
>> BUT.
>> BUT -- [LAUGHTER].
>> I'M NOT GOING TO SAY I TOLD
YOU SO BUT.
>> IF ONLY WE COULD REPROGRAM
THOSE ROBOTS LAURA BUT WHAT CAN
YOU DO?
YOU DO YOUR BEST.
I WISH WE COULD HAVE SEEN THAT
ROBOT.
>> Laura: WE DIDN'T SEE IT BUT
WE SAW THE CLIP OF IT EARLIER
AND IT WAS CREEPY.
THERE IT IS.
CAN'T REALLY SEE IT.
LOOKS LIKE AN INSECT.
>> ELON MUSK SAID I'LL BE --
THIS WILL FUNDAMENTALLY
TRANSFORM CIVILIZATION.
>> Laura: LOVELY.
>> THIS SCARES THE DAYLIGHTS OUT
OF ME LAURA.
LOVE AND CARE IS SOMETHING NO
ROBOT CAN DO.
WE NEED TO TEACH PEOPLE TO DO
THINGS AND SER